eran aproximadamente las nueve de la
mañana y un aire de incertidumbre
golpeaba niza de nuevo un ataque
terrorista sacudía la ciudad en esta
ocasión era la basílica de notre damme
una iglesia en el centro de la ciudad
que en ese momento no celebraba servicio
alguno
la presencia de la policía hacía temer
lo peor un sujeto armado con un cuchillo
entró a la iglesia y mató a tres
personas dos fieles y un sacristán
acabamos de ver en la televisión que el
sacristán de nuestra iglesia fue
asesinado
estoy en shock aún me lo imagino lo veo
caminando encendiendo las velas
escuché sirenas la policía llegó rápido
muy rápido llegaron en moto y luego todo
lo demás yo fue una de las fieles una
mujer mayor fue de capital de la iglesia
el sacristán también murió en este
recinto y la otra víctima mortal llegó a
escapar con mi vida a un bar en donde
falleció eran de los pocos que en ese
momento estaban en la iglesia la policía
redujo al atacante un sujeto que según
los primeros indicios llegó solo al
lugar del crimen los feto camps
no hay ninguna duda sobre las
motivaciones y la determinación de este
agresor quien constantemente repetía ala
es grande mientras era asistido
médicamente soplas
hace 4 años otro ataque de corte
islamista en luto a niza un hombre a
bordo de un camión arrolló una multitud
que presenciaba los tradicionales fuegos
artificiales del día de la bastilla el
ataque terminó con un saldo de 86
muertos y cientos de heridos